people of the internet retro racking
tour here if we are meeting for the
first time i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell
we are back with another episode of
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
or harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
again depending on your territory and
we are getting ready to take norbert
off to the tower where he can go with
charlie
and right now we are under the
invisibility
invisibility why can i not say that
right now invisibility cloak
and as you can see there filch right in
our line of sight
and we are trying to avoid him to
get the dragon there safely i'm not sure
where the dragon is now but you know hey
it's an old game we're just going to
pretend he's got the dragon with him
unfortunately our health is below half
right now
and kind of the i i guess that sort of
the drawback to having the invisibility
cloak is whenever you want to cast a
spell
he will indeed have to come out from
under the cloak so see there how
he goes visible whenever he's casting a
spell all right but we don't really need
to worry about casting a spell right now
so
of course remember filch could still
hear us so we're going to take it very
slowly here harry you can't be making
noise like that dude
you can't be making noise like that how
do we get up here can i not get up there
i want
i want to get that bean
harry are you serious against the troll
you jumped over like a huge chasm
and here for whatever reason you can't
make it right there
oh dude did he hear me oh he did
man he did so you do have to walk slowly
okay
true to the book then if that is the
case
all right let's go ahead and jump over
here i can't believe i'm doing this for
a single birdie bop bean
i i really can't believe it
i cannot believe i'm doing that for okay
two birdie bop beans
two birdy bop beans we're at 405 now
all right and then we should be able to
wait for him okay he's gone
oh what a nice touch having him whisper
aloha mora there
what's going on who was that
now the door closes all right oh
not fair not fair filch
it's just not fair guys thank you so
much for
stopping by and hanging out really
appreciate all the support if you enjoy
this video and enjoy this
series make sure you leave a like here
so give it a thumbs up
and i am always on the lookout for new
content ideas so if you guys have an
idea for videos you'd like to see me
make or other games you'd like to see me
do let's plays for
be sure and let me know down in the
comments
because i am always reading the comments
i promise you guys always reading them
and trying to respond to as many as i
can
we are not going to let you find us
now the hard part is when mrs norris
shows up you know she's gonna show up at
some point
you just know
all right again i can't believe i'm
doing this just for a couple of
oh dude we almost fell right on top of
his head
almost fell right on top of his head
okay let's can we get over there i don't
think it matters
just want to make sure there wasn't like
an alohomora secret
secret right there come on harry
grab on dude all right you know what
forget it i'm honestly i'm gonna try it
one more time
and if i don't get it i'm really not
worried about that single bean
it's it's it's one single bean
all right so yeah let him go ahead and
check out he's not gonna find me over
there right now
anything else over there more stairs on
that side
okay forget it i really don't care about
the bean
i really do not care about the bean
we've got so many at this point
and fred and george just keep giving us
duplicates anyway so
they keep giving us duplicates anyway
you guys
all right hit the save point
phillips takes another secret passage so
he's probably gonna be in this room here
[Applause]
oh that was close that was close
that was dangerously close all right
first i want to see what's over here
though
[Applause]
how can i get up there is he going to
find me i really hope not
well well are in
trouble now aren't we filled
dude that was sneaky man
i thought he would still be
investigating the first spot i really
did
all right he's gonna investigate over
there
all right open that door then i'm gonna
run over here
yeah yeah he's just so gleeful
he is so gleeful when he thinks he's
about to catch you
students out of bed
okay let's see if we walk around here
which way is he gonna go
i think he went that way
yeah he did now how can i get up there
i know how
hop up here hop over here
hop over here why not add another birdie
bob bean that one was a lot easier to
get to
all right there we go okay
let's see i don't think he can get up
here but
yeah he's gonna go in there
okay i don't think i can get through
this gate right now so
we're gonna have to go back down
oh my gosh i thought he was gonna run in
there
i thought he was gonna run in there
honestly though i i really gotta applaud
them for having
the nice touch of having him whisper
instead of just
shouting flupindo like normal people who
are
uh younger might be thinking what like
it's really not that big a deal
trust me like that is that is a really
nice touch that they
they thought to add that can i go
through here no
okay i honestly i don't even know what
door just opened
what door opened right there so see we
already went up here
we already went there's nothing over
there
we already did that i guess i have to go
back up huh
oh right there there's how we get
through
okay and then it's gonna have that
statue up here where i believe we can
cast
lumos i don't know he's hiding maybe we
have to
hit the flipino switch first
nope that one opened another one down
below
very interesting okay now i'm i'm
intrigued to know how
we get in there like all that's in that
room
is can i see up oh maybe you no i was
gonna say maybe you fall down but
it doesn't look like there's anything
above
okay let's go back down here go back
over here so now we can go through this
area
and looks like something's gonna be
happening in this room
there it is all right so now we're gonna
have to go back
and turn uh use lumos on the statue
could you imagine if phil's caught me
now i'd be so annoyed
he's so annoyed because i think you'd
have to redo this whole little section
here
be very tedious to have to do it again
like one time through i don't mind it's
not too bad but
i haven't had any checkpoints lately so
all right so hopefully that opens
something
there we go all right now where filch is
a squib
he shouldn't be able to see those
platforms right
because they are part of this
lumo spell which we know is not an
accurate
it's not an accurate to the book lumos
but
we're just gonna go with it i'm just
gonna roll with it it works
all right a single birdy bop bean and
another
so hopefully we need to remember there
is a higher
area right in there so this is not the
end
okay this spot i believe we have no
choice but to drop down
all right we got two things we can hit a
flipindo switch i don't know that we
should have done that because now it's
gonna let
filch back in here right or did it block
him
oh he takes the secret passage because
of course he does
okay is he gonna appear right in here
[Applause]
all right what does that open up gives
us more of those
okay so are we gonna have to go back
we're gonna have to go back to that
previous room right
in here i still don't know where filch
is either i don't like that
i wish i had a better idea of exactly
where he's lurking about right now
all right now we should be able to just
keep going up
there we go nicely done harry come on
pull yourself
up man perfect perfect
oh can he make that jump
i think he can guys i think he can i
think he can
there we go all right very nicely done
another lumos here
[Music]
so back the way we came
yet again
all right now we got to make that long
jump
there we go oh he didn't even need to
pull up right there
and another bean just for good measure
perfect
all right phil took another secret
passes though so i i don't think we're
those moving no i don't think we're
finished with filts just yet
let's see because we still got the
invisibility cloak so that tells me that
there might be a reason that they still
have
the invisibility cloak on harry right
here
music dude the suspense
all right
wait a second can he make
that jump about to find out
okay i'm actually kind of shocked that
he was able to jump that eye
all right there's phil so now we know
where he is he's going to be
roaming around this area right here so
let's just kind of very quietly go
i want to check where he came oh he's i
gotta move
i gotta i gotta run i don't have a
choice
oh no we're at a dead end i don't like
this
oh i did not need to jump i did not need
to jump
for some reason whenever you right click
that also doubles as the jump button
we could probably turn it off but okay
let's get in here
okay we got a switch right here all
right he's he's
he's going back and forth pretty yeah i
was about to say we need to wait a
second before we hit the switch
let him get by
all right so that's gonna turn that
around
he's gonna take it across okay he's just
gonna wait for me on the other side
i think i'm blind i'm not letting anyone
into that
tower tonight come on phil we're trying
to do a good thing
trust me you do not want the dragon to
be let loose in hogwarts that is not
what you want phil
all right i'm just gonna make sure
there's nothing over here okay no
secrets or anything
all right so you guys see what we have
to do here don't you
anything you see you notice i'll give
you a chance if you haven't caught it
yet anything we could use
maybe to distract our boy filch
okay i missed right there but i don't
want him to be looking at me when i cast
it
i'm going to try and break one of those
with flupindo
oh can we not hit it from here can we
not hit it from here with the flipindo
oh i better know what you have to do do
i have to go over here first
no because then he doesn't have like a
huh okay maybe you're not supposed to do
that i thought i thought for sure that i
would i would flipindo one of those make
it break
yeah it's like now it's even giving me
the big hint
oh no leaves you'll be
banished for this
i don't think so phil should see if i
have to distract philips along the way
okay fine we just figured it out before
the game told us here's what to do
yeah phil basically has been at hogwarts
since it opened
yeah i don't i don't know how i'm going
to do this you guys like because he's
looking right
there we go there we go
and into the astronomy tower we go
[Music]
ron's brother charlie hey charlie what's
up dude
from the tower and return him to romania
it's not even going to show him he's
just like a black shadow
[Music]
bye norbert
all right now we're going to have to get
back
back into the gryffindor common room and
we still haven't ran into mrs norris
though you guys
wait what is he doing okay
oh there she is there she
is i could have sworn i had footsteps in
here but
yeah let's check the library my sweet
alright so now we got two to avoid on
our way back
all right so they're through there
or he said let's check the library so
maybe i don't have to worry about them
until we get
oh there they are okay is this door
gonna shut though
yes it does that's pretty cool though
that you can catch up to him i wonder if
i would have kept running would it have
let me just like
follow him on through
okay she's gonna hop up top
you'll not get past me now you rotten
little gutter snipes
oh filch man they went all out with
filter in this game
rotten little gutter snipes dude that
is so ridiculously close to the mark of
the deathly hallows
she's missing the wand i mean are you
serious
that is amazing i mean obviously
not intentional because i don't think jk
rowling had informed anyone about that
at this point okay what are we what are
we supposed to do here we can't just
walk right up to him
oh jeez why is she down here
i thought she's supposed to be up top
okay wait how do we oh there's flapindo
right
there
all right there she is dude is she like
i think she might be glitched
she's stuck
watch she's gonna hop up here as soon as
i get up here though
all right let's jump across right here
jump across right here don't even worry
about mrs norris
and what's over there is that a
i don't think there's anything special
but we'll double check
looks just like a book but not a save
game or anything
uh did you guys just hear that was that
oh
is that a werewolf
what is happening book three is not
out yet my friends is this
what is this it's a little owl statue
okay
i know i said i would go back and check
that but i didn't think we were done
with that room i'm not going back
because pretty sure there's nothing of
note there
yep and we still got bayou filch we got
bayou and mrs norris she couldn't figure
out how to get up on the top area
okay let's grab this save point right
here
intruder okay
nothing we can do here at least i don't
think so
yeah oh dude
he sounds like he heard me
okay all right we're good we're good
we're good
there's not like a walk button because
it's on the the keyboard
so oh dude she is stuck again
she can't get up top like she's supposed
to
okay let's just do something over here
okay this is where it all starts yo
there's a ghost though
can he see through the invisibility
cloak oh my goodness he can
how's the bean collecting friend george
are up to their usual tricks
no nick
yes just go go don't talk to me buddy
okay hop across there
what if he just starts talking to you
when you're out here and it gives away
your position
oh wait really is that it no okay there
we go
all right hop across here okay another
gate but dude there is so much to
explore in here no no no
no do not do not do that harry
all right i think it'll come back around
but yeah like right there i don't know
how i'm supposed to get those
birdie bop beans not that i'm short on
beans or anything we've got plenty of
beans let me tell you
oh he hears me
that's what i get dude that's what i get
for talking a big game man
that's what i get for talking a big game
not gonna find me up here phil
and then we just completely botch a jump
we've been doing so well
been doing so well on all of our jumps
and then we
fell right on top of filch i mean just
right on top of him okay
at least now even though it's going to
be kind of tedious to do this again we
know we know exactly what to do we're
going to go here
then nick's going to come out and say
hello how's it going harry
really you can't skip this all right
i'll skip it for you guys though
george are up to their usual tricks i
presume
i heard about your quidditch victory yes
well done harry
on to the copy what on to the copy what
okay what do you say we try this again
in the forbidden corridor
there we go much better harry
much better that time okay
let's go around here
i think nick is acting as like a little
a guide for me okay
go through here come on come on there we
go
i'll catch you and when i do you
don't worry i'm not gonna smack talk him
anymore guys
no more smack talking of filch because
the last time i tried that
you guys all saw what happened it was
not pretty what
oh i was like what is that mrs norris
dude
she finally figured out how to get up to
the top area
oh dang she's following me holy
i was not expecting that okay i gotta go
over here and check this first though i
gotta just i gotta just gotta make sure
there's not something special over here
really that's it just the door
a blocked door alright fine
okay back down we go i know there's a
door right there but i just want to make
sure
imagine if he saw me through there and
came rushing through i would have been
so mad
out of it so mad okay
i think we're getting close guys oh
the mirror of era said wow
no way dude
i forgot this was in the game man these
parents
i did i just do not remember this hungry
back as though hoping to fall
right through the glass and reach them
he was startled when a voice sounded
behind him
okay so they do they kind of skip ahead
so you
like hundreds before you have discovered
the delights of the mirror of erised
said indeed dumbledore he went on to
explain
that the mirror showed nothing more or
nothing less
than the deepest most desperate desire
of our hearts but that it would give
neither knowledge nor
truth the mirror of error said will be
moved to a new home
shortly dumbledore went on adding
ominously that if harry
ever came across it again he would be
prepared
but prepared for what
i wonder
oh no are you serious we're not done
with mrs norris yet gave us the slip
okay good yeah i've locked the only door
out of here
stay here and watch the library for a
bit my dear
dude i was just with dumbledore man come
on
dumbledore give me a hand here dude
that's hilarious though like you're just
with the headmaster but then you've got
to sneak past the caretaker to get back
to your
dormitory wait what
there we go still i point out we have
not
had a an opportunity for
a chocolate frog in quite some time
oh the ominous music it's back
okay hit that save point oh come on come
on
yes give me a chocolate frog out of here
dude
chocolate frog please
weak just terribly weak i don't even
know if you can
get chocolate frogs out of those i'm
pretty sure you can i feel like i've
gotten one before
ah just a standard portrait here no
secrets there
all right so i think this is the room
where mrs norris is first
okay let's go this side
scan the area here i don't see anything
like it's giving me the ominous music
but i don't see her maybe she's still
here
oh yikes they're down there
thanks for telling me exactly how to get
out
oh he heard that okay
all right they're ready for me they
already
can i just stay up here go across the
top
i think you can dude
oh my goodness
no
okay we did all that for one bean
okay so the question is how do we
[Music]
all right is it i'm guessing there's
going to be flapindo switches somewhere
okay so we got filch on
that side and mrs norris is so small man
we need to locate her i don't know
where she went she like right below
i don't think so about to find out
though
okay so they're like weights we have to
[Applause]
well that's gonna make some noise
back up harry
okay she moved on
i think we're gonna have to do it two
two times on each side
is he coming this way i think he was
i'm gonna go right here just in case
oh come on can i not reach it
there we go now in truth harry
should be able to just walk right under
that
but i have a feeling that they want me
to raise it two more times let's see
oh come on dude come on
maybe it's meant to be like a lock
though i'll buy that
oh she's over there okay good she is
over there not even close
wait what is it gonna slide back down
though
i don't think so i think it's good
go on mrs norris nothing to see here
all right one more one more
and filth was so far away i think i have
time to just
stand right here and do it
gotta move a little bit closer
all right there we go it should be open
now
should be open
someone's got past me not yet we haven't
filled not yet
getting close though
come on open the doors yo
peeps perfect timing peeps
you'll be banished for this that's what
he says to him every time
you know peace is not getting banished
they've let him hang around this long is
not gonna happen okay so it's just mrs
norris left
all right where's she at oh she's right
there dude
all right so we're gonna have to do i
think i think we're gonna have to
yep come and investigate mrs norris
and then we are out of here
oh my goodness is that really not it
is that still not it oh fred and george
what's up
what's up dudes
come on give me an actual card that i
don't have yet this time
please
wait what they're not even gonna talk to
me
is the game glitching or am i supposed
to be hearing them talk right now
nice timing though guys very nice timing
as we descend into the depths of
hogwarts
all right all right
[Music]
nothing to do there let's see where this
goes though
hey harry do you have 25 beats oh
yes i do hey you better get those
that's it that's all the beans we need
what
let's go
come on new wizard card baby new wizard
card
that's a new one we really needed these
that's one i didn't have here about us
collecting beans
it will be our secret right okay fine
come on george
we've got what so what do you guys want
me to do
with all these extra beans that i have
though that's what i want to know
what am i supposed to do with all these
extra beans
all right i'm gonna walk over here and
check oh it won't let me any closer are
you serious okay fine let's check out
what that
wizard card is right there right here
rowena ravenclaw medieval wizard dates
unknown co-founder of hogwarts
gave her name to one of the four
hogwarts houses
very cool very cool and that is where we
are going to end this episode guys
if you're enjoying this series and you
enjoy the content here on the youtube
channel then make sure you subscribe
ring the bell so you don't miss any of
the new videos and i appreciate you guys
so so much thank you all for watching
and i'll talk to you again soon